jutta witali klitschko wladimir
klitschko wir stehen hier vor einem
gebäude in kiew was angegriffen wurde
deutschland hat man das gefühl der krieg
ist nur noch im osten gesehen hier und
hier können sehr wohl noch was passieren
eine woche virus städten die flügel
macht unsere stadt und
werk zerstört ja das ist so genannte
spezielle attraktion was russen sagen
gegen die militärische arm halten nicht
nur noch einmal zu sagen das ist das ist
eine unbemannte wer hier produziert seit
vier jahrhunderten
und niemals militärische equipment
produziert und was in diesem verbund was
kann passieren getreide
und meine meinung nach genau das
gleich getroffen wie
unternehmen diese gebäude wobei für
getreide produziert das ist reine und
ganz europa auskommen
die sind sowie einzige sehen wieso
diese unternehmen haben wladimir du bist
genauso wie vita liegen seit beginn des
krieges vor dem krieg in kiew wie fühlt
sich die stadt an für euch momentan und
wie fühlt sich das dann an wenn man
sowas sieht hier
das leben ist zurück in der stadt das
kann man spüren vergleich wie das anfang
oder mitte märz gewesen das war eine
geisterstadt es waren keine menschen das
waren keine autos keine fahrzeugen jetzt
ist das natürlich das leben so zu sagen
und ich zog aber der frieden ist deshalb
wirklich genauso wie
sie haben gerade gesagt gebäude ist
hinter uns ehemalige gebäude also von
dem gebäude sind module ihnen geblieben
man sieht auch dass diese frieden und
diese lebens setzte blech und es kann
passieren jede musik ohne jeden moment
die tränen laufen nach wie vor wie
gesagt nur vor paar tagen woche her ist
sind die vier ketten angeschlagen wurden
in einer stadt wie sind in der stadt
positiv
und wie gesagt man muss wirklich dann
daraus auch einiges tun weil der himmel
in unsere köpfe ist nicht sicher und das
muss auch europa verstehen wenn sie an
die wiesn teil von europa wir sind teil
von eco system das ist auch der sinn
dieses angriffs und um die getreide zu
stoppen um hunger nicht nur nach asien
oder afrika wo die ukraine böse schwarze
meer diese geteilte liefert sondern
diese ganze kommunikation was
lebensmitteln betrifft auch in der
ukraine 1000 wochen betroffen wird jetzt
sehen wir vor allem im osten heftige
kämpfe und wir hören die warnung dass
die ukraine vitali nicht genügend
munition hat nicht genügend waffen wie
entscheidend ist die phase momentan im
donbass
blauer himmel sonne
für das ist
denke ich mal in europa auch eine
täuschung dass es eine frieden gibt es
eine deutschland das ist das manko dass
vorher eine richtige schlacht
und
robustheit eingreifen ukraine und
russland hat mehr soldatenberufs um hat
wissend dass wegen dem brauchen dringend
unterstützung weil ich noch einmal
betonen ich noch einmal wiederholen für
ihre erhaltung wir verteidigen nicht
unserer später und seine familien und
unser land wir verteidigen auch wie
werde was rat für ihre demokratischen
europäischen staat aber trifft es zu
dass die munition ausgeht um aus was
geht was geht die munition wir brauchen
unterstützung wir brauchen eine emotion
immerhin so wir brauchen wenn man wenn
man während der woche die tagungsleitung
weil wir greifen an keine wir
verteidigen unsere was passiert wenn
diese waffen in den nächsten tagen und
wochen nicht kommen das bedeutet noch
mehr auch keine schuld hätten
sterben die kämpfen gibt einfache war
von gegen moderne waffen was das berufs-
und
wir müssen uns verteidigen beteiligung
unsere
soldaten gewarnt dass das so wichtig
heute eine moderne schwere waffen zu
bekommen ich möchte noch einmal die
beteiligung war wie grafiken für die
jungs war vladimir droht die ukraine
diesen krieg gerade im osten zu
verlieren und wenn das passieren sollte
ist es auch die schuld des westens war
keine waffen kommen also die schuld
deutschlands frankreichs all dieser
länder die bislang nicht so viel
geliefert haben wie die ukraine sich
wünscht was die schulen betrifft man
kann das hin und herschieben schuld
liegt dann russische seite definitiv an
diesem krieg
es ist wichtig zu verstehen wenn wir
fallen fällt ihr auch wir sind in einem
ökosystem wie sind für bohnen
miteinander
frieden demokratie diese schöne welt was
beschrieben wird wird hier zu starten
und wie gesagt wenn wir fahren und
werdet auch erfahren was passiert da
gerade im osten wir sehen die schlachten
im donbass viele deutsche kennen diese
ortsnamen nicht so wirklich slavia nsk
amateurs könnte als nächstes war halt
aus eurer sicht will putin dann noch
weiter wird er wieder versuchen auch
größere städte wie oder sbisa borussia
und am heck er auf jeden fall tief war
ein ziel und bleibt einzig und nicht nur
putin schon persönlich sagt er bekommt
die
die die territorium was hat gehört haben
seine in serie und wir mussten auch nie
vergessen dass es zum inter das ist
schwierig und die stimme von hofer die
ich hier und gewaltige lernte ich hörte
vor man sollte das auch chris paktiert
bleiben vitali also das heißt du glaubst
dass wenn er im osten erfolgreich ist er
erneut versuchen wird auf die hauptstadt
zu marschieren er wird weiter
marschieren und rm seine interesse endet
nicht in essen sogar seine größe und
besonnen endet nicht im qi und nicht die
grenze rät pommer ich bin fest überzeugt
wie putin geht soweit wir weiter wer
wasser umzugehen und sie schließt nicht
aus dass es eher durch muss und nicht
vergessen wie ein teil von deutschland
wahr auch ein teil von für ethische
imperia
wladimir du nimmst du momentan die
debatte in europa und insbesondere in
deutschland war um diesen krieg es ist
ein bisschen weniger
aufmerksamkeit natürlich nach diesen
monaten was macht das mit dir
das ausdauer spielt eine wichtige rolle
diese krieg ist leidet sie sich durch
mehrere monate und wahrscheinlich mal
wird auch müde seien wahrscheinlich wird
man nur seine in deutschland von den
ukrainer zu fragen bitte helfen sie
helfen und mehr helfen und so lange
diese glück läuft muss diese
unterstützung stattfinden humanitäre
unterstützung militärische unterstützung
und jeder andere weil er
krieg
zerstört das leben
und es wird eine therapie klopfen an der
tür den deutschen klopfen macht man das
man darf das nicht unterschätzen weil es
muss schon über drei monate und es gibt
noch mehr lernen und leben gelaufen und
werden noch mehr erleben und gebäude
zerstört jetzt haben wir berichtet dass
noch in diesem monat bis zum
g7 gipfel
olaf scholz emanuel marcon mario draghi
eine reise planen genau terminiert ist
sie nicht öffentlich wiedergeben wie
oder was wünscht du dir von diesen drei
staatschefs wenn sie kommen was sollten
sie mitbringen was ist das wichtigste
für die ukraine gerade
seit monaten wird geliefert die
unterstützung kommt bald die
gespräche mit militär wollte das ist ein
teil von unterstützung kommt aber nicht
zu ihnen die eingewöhnung schon wer und
was bedeutet das bedeutet die
wir verlieren zu verlieren sie ein teil
von fill verliert
menschenleben und müssen wir auch nicht
vergessen weil
berufs umdenken so weit zu marschieren
dass
das dann gefährlich für jede europäer
seien und wer eine falsche einstellung
wenn jemand in deutschland denkt wie
krieg weit weg bestimmt nicht das srk
betroffen werden in europäischen jetzt
also die drei sollen mit rang ich
brauche ich wir brauchen führung 34
mediaform gelände
habe der unterstützungsaktion waffen und
lieferung schnell wie möglich grund für
die liste von waffen haben wir schon am
allen werden gegeben und
das ist sie
jeden monat dass es tausend war so jeder
jede stunde jeder tag zählt wladimir
wenn du daran denkst dass diese drei
startet demnächst irgendwann hier nach
kiel kommen könnten oder kommen werden
was ist ein dringender wunsch ich glaube
man kann das besser fühlen und sehen
wenn man mit schärpe und gästen besucht
es ist nicht mehr so wie es mal war im
märz als die russische armee diese
stätte verlassen hat aber wenn die drei
chefs das mit den eigenen augen sehen
und spüren auch und auch die menschen
treffen dann werden die glaube ich mehr
emotional aufgeladen um diese hilfe die
sind notwendig hilfe uns zu geben mit
allem zeug waffen kommentars hilfe
finanzielle hilfe um so weiter deswegen
wir aber ganz wichtig wie am lauten zu
sein wie könnte wenn diese drei in kiew
sind und mit seelands gesprächen und mit
euch möglicherweise sprechen
werden sie auch danach fragen wie kann
frieden aussehen in der ukraine und da
gibt es ja verschiedene debatten die
einen sagen man muss jetzt verhandeln
andere sagen auf gar keinen fall solange
putin auch ukraine territorium ist wie
ist deine meinung dazu auch hier fallen
die frisur muss nicht so aussehen nur
über unsere hauptstadt mehr als 300
gebäude
mehr als 100 mehr als 120 menschen
gestorben vier kinder
und wir wünschen wir wünschen frieden in
ganz europa und wir müssen gemeinsam der
gemeinsam mit
gemeinsamer kraft alles machen die
briten zuletzt noch kleine bringen das
ist eine riesige russland machen
er beschaffte wir wirtschaftlich
sanktionen wirken sehr gut um noch
einmal wir sind bereit zu kämpfen zur
gänze und beseitigen nicht nur unsere
familie teiligen auch hier den regierung
die wir erklären muss dass alles
begreifen um so etwas kaufen wir gesehen
wie nicht
im besten in europa ich habe nie gedacht
so etwas kann passieren in unserer
hauptstadt und hoffe ich hoffe ich dass
etwas mit mir wie europa passieren aber
gibt es möglichkeiten wenn putin sagt
oder putins truppen die ukraine
zumindest im osten nicht verlassen
werden immer weiter kämpfe werden dann
kann es ja ein ewiger krieg werden
wir
alles machen sie zu stoppen
es ist unmöglich ewig wird das nicht
darum klare isolierung wirtschaftliche
isolierung von russland und
unterstützung der ukraine mit waffen mit
hilfe einer zelle hilfe dieser krieg
wird nicht lange dauern ich bin davon
fest überzeugt werden diese
unterstützung kommt die lange glaubst du
monatlich werden wären putins russland
wird es nicht
sehen dass die ganze welt ist gegen
diese aggression dann geht es einfach
weitergehen aber die welt muss es mit
einer front in eine front stehen gegen
nurmehr diese gegen bild von dieser
regierung und damit auch zeigen wie sie
in termin nicht einverstanden ist muss
gestoppt werden nur so russische
wirtschaft
europäische wirtschaft und die brauchen
ersatzteile
beschafft und seine seine eltern seine
geschafft für seine sogar militär und
deswegen diskussion gibt sind wir gut
und deswegen bitte
stoppen die geld dann ruf vom schicken
weil das energie sanktion konstruktion
olgas weil sie ihre ideen
die ihr geld für euro was wird nach
osten geschickt dass ich nicht weil geld
wird sofort investiert um dann
sehen wir solche bilder nicht nur
entgeht auch im
du wirst du keine und oberen kopf in
richtung europa deswegen gemeinsam unser
das sind das alles zu stoppen wie nimmt
man in der ukraine die debatte um
wladimir putins gesundheitszustand war
es gibt ja immer die frage was hat er
für eine krankheit wie lange könnte er
noch leben ist das ein thema in der
ukraine
diejenigen von millionen von menschen
zerstört
vorerst diese krieg angefangen und
erkannt diese krieg stoppen und wenn man
stoppt nicht gefährlich stopp nicht um
sehr viele diskussion vielleicht stärker
städte weil es tatsächlich die zeit zu
leben das ist viel spekulation gegen
krankheiten das tram fahre nicht wieso
hat diese krieg angefangen
ich noch bin ich da auch ich habe keine
infos darüber zu diskutieren das ist nur
spekulation reine spekulation aber die
wunsch von millionen menschen leben ist
zerstört und für tausende von menschen
abnehmen verfahren
ein
riesige hohen sprit oder
losgehen oder muss verschwinden oder
muss zum award musik und musste die
führung
ist das die hoffnung der ukraine das war
dass vladimir putin sterben könnte das
ist die hoffnung von der ganzen welt
egal was es ist das schickal gestoppt
wird mit jedem mittel
weil diese zerstörung diese tötung
förderung völkermord muss gestoppt
werden mit den mitteln das spielt es
spielt keine rolle weil zu viele
menschen leiden nicht nur war also vor
allem auch kinder bis 1000 kinder sind
getötet wurden oder verletzt worden in
diesem krieg letzte frage viele deutsche
haben in den vergangenen monaten seit
beginn des krieges auf euch geschaut
auch wie es euch geht auch ihr standl
auf oder steht auf einer todesliste von
wladimir putin wie geht es euch heute
und was ist die sorge um das eigene
leben momentan auch in kiel
wie ihr der trainer aber befindet sich
in ukraine steht und ihr risiko barriere
sich und ihre mittel bekamen eine rakete
her zu land und in jedem gebäude werden
der staat hier die gebäude unserer wand
und deswegen die ukraine steht den
risiko zu sterben ich habe keine angst
davor die selbstständige wusste nicht
wie wohl schon für jede
so lernen wir wie möglich leben zu
genießen aber wie dieses unseres plans
und halten unsere stärke und deswegen
unsere vater ehemalige militär hat uns
beigebracht
für eine große ehre
zu stellen und so seine eigene waren
seine familie ich habe wir wollen nichts
da wo
bekommt man keine angst
vladimir du bist auch eben seit beginn
oder vor beginn des krieges hier wie
geht es dir mittlerweile das eine und
das andere du bist gestern in die living
legend aufgenommen worden der boxer
bitterlich schon seit ein paar jahren
dabei ist was ist das für ein gefühl
hier in der ukraine zu sein
obwohl du eigentlich wahrscheinlich in
den usa hätte sein sollen um diese
ehrung aufzunehmen die vintage ganz
anderes vor dem krieg und jetzt während
des kriegs
mittelzone ich
eigentlich nicht mehr so wichtig wo ich
gerade bin oder sein sollte in canastota
beiden hoffen natürlich ein vergangenen
leben als sportler
es ist eine ehre da zu sein aber es ist
noch größere größere ehre hier zu sein
in der ukraine und
noch größere ehre diesen frieden doch zu
verteidigen in der ukraine und es ist
nicht nur der ukraine sondern dass auch
betrieb den ganzen welt und deswegen bin
ich hier und deswegen ist es schön zu
wissen dass irgendwo gefeiert werde
genauso wie man wurde dass wir beide
jetzt in hall of fame in canastota
unseren platz oder die namen sie und
rein geschrieben und das bleibt so
herzlichen dank vitali klitschko und
wladimir klitschko wir sehen hier die
zerstörung hinter uns das genau ist vor
einer woche passiert und dass auch als
botschaft für diejenigen die glauben
dass der krieg kiew nicht mehr erreichen
könnte wir sehen hinter uns auch kiew
ist immer noch in ständiger gefahr
herzlichen dankeschön